people arriving from Sudan get two hot
meals a day usually eight agencies give
out food rations so families can cook
for themselves but this is just a
Transit Center in South Sudan people
cross the border with very few
belongings these meals help them survive
until they get to their final
destination
I have three children and this food is
not enough to feed them we are grateful
but it's not enough
humanitarian agencies say around 6 000
people arrive every day in South Sudan a
country where thousands have already
been displaced by insecurity and floods
we have more than 7.76 million people
who are facing food insecurity in the
country that's two-thirds of the
population and we are we are providing
assistance to a lot of them around 5.7
million so we'll have to take some of
these resources to respond to this
crisis
most of women and children with no money
clothes or shelter
they're here for too long they need to
move on because there aren't enough
resources to help everyone
towns on the border with Sudan have also
been affected by the conflict prices of
some staple foods have doubled because
transport and trade have been disrupted
all those good they come from Sudan so
all the roads are knocked across it so
we have no way again to get the goods
done
South Sudan Imports many items from its
neighbor there are fears there will be
further price increases and shortages
not just here but also in other
countries in the region
South Sudan